all right
welcome to the first philosophy
pop-up of the the year uh
2021 and i thought that i would uh
talk a little bit today about something
that i've devoted
a lot of thought to in the past and that
is new year's resolutions
as a matter of fact i even linked to a
workshop that i did
about new year's resolutions a number of
years ago when we first moved here
to milwaukee uh i think it might have
been 2017
about using stoicism to reassess and
keep new year's resolutions
so i'm going to talk for a bit and then
i'm sure people have comments and
questions about all sorts of things
and you know my ideas are fairly brief
i'm going to tell you a little bit of a
story about new year's
and um i'm going to tell you why i think
new year's resolutions are not something
necessarily bad
but they're not the best idea i think
that
that there's something that we might
want to revise and so maybe resolutions
isn't the best term for for these sorts
of things
and i'll give you some suggestions about
what
uh a different approach would look like
and then you know i've been devoting in
the last few days
some time to thinking about what i want
more of
in in this new year for myself
and my wife and i have also been doing
that you know things that we're gonna do
together
and have started doing together um
but i'm going to talk specifically about
the things that i think would add more
enjoyment you know downtime whatever to
my life and then you might think about
things
along similar lines and we can certainly
like have a conversation back and forth
andrew asks
can we ask questions after new year's
resolutions absolutely as a matter of
fact i'm i'm going to suggest to you
that when it comes to your own new
year's resolutions you
you want to ask yourself questions about
them
uh namely do i want to stick with these
these commitments that i've made or make
make new commitments so i'm going to i'm
going to start out by telling you a
story
and this will be a little bit off topic
but it might be
interesting to some of you when i was a
kid
we would not only make new year's
resolutions we would also
make new year's predictions and we would
write them down on a piece of paper
and then put them in an envelope and
then we would
um you know open them up the next
next year sometimes we didn't actually
wait till new year's now that i think
about it
um and so you know it'd be things like i
predict that
you know uh jimmy carter will be
president again here this would be like
you know
19 what 1980 um
or that you know so and so is going to
grow
five inches this year whatever right and
interestingly my dad who many of you
probably know my adoptive father
anton sadler he he died in 1982
and he was only 36 years old when he
died and they never did figure out what
it was fever
unknown origin it was labeled at the
mayo clinic
and he actually wrote in his prediction
tony sadler will not be here with us um
in in 19 in the end of 1982 or i guess
in 1983 or however he wrote it
and we opened it up and it was it was
you know quite something to see that
he must have known that he was he was
ill in some way
um but you know he hadn't started
showing anything and he
and nobody knew what he had so it was
kind of an
eerie thing to find after the fact i
don't remember what i wrote in any of my
predictions
in the many years that we did that we
used to actually get together with
another family
the islams who were close friends of our
family
and make these predictions together and
it was quite a lot of fun but then
there's the
so that's an interesting little little
tidbit story but then there's the whole
idea of making resolutions right
here's why i think resolutions
understood as resolutions not in a very
broad sense where it can mean anything
that you want but
as actual commitments that a person
makes i i don't think that new year's
resolutions are a good idea
that said if you find them useful for
you know straightening out your life i'm
not gonna knock you or say that that you
shouldn't do it
i'm just saying i think that for a lot
of people
it's actually counterproductive to make
new year's resolutions so
here's here's a couple reasons why and
maybe some of you have some ideas why
i mean damn it albert says 2020 taught
me to avoid predictions
it might also teach us to avoid certain
kinds of resolutions
um we're still in covid time we don't
know when we're going to get out of it
you know the vaccine uh rollout here in
the united states has been
kind of a uh a mess to say the least
you know so here's a few reasons why i
think new year's resolutions are
problematic
one of them is that we make them at the
worst time you know
there's this there's this sort of
pressure to come up with something on
the first
of the year when a lot of people are
probably
hungover from partying the night before
maybe not so much this time
but um you know uh
it's it's not an ideal time to try to
decide what you're going to do unless
you've really devoted a lot of thought
to it already ahead of time
in the days leading up to it
i think actually it's good to take like
a whole week and
think through the if you're going to
make a big commitment
and you're gonna like do it in a public
way think through the implications
and the practical logistical
requirements for doing that if you're
gonna say like i'm gonna hit the gym
every day
well what if your gym is closed you know
um what if
you get sick what if all these other
things come up you want to
think these things through so you know
this is sort of
shifting into a second thing a lot of
new year's resolutions are very
unrealistic
and i've made my share of them in the
past i'd be like i'm going to lose
20 pounds this year you know i'm going
to go to the gym every single
day i'm going to learn a new language
you know um
those are some big commitments and
it's almost better to start out with if
you're going to change a habit if you're
going to change your life
you start out with baby steps right you
start with something
manageable and so i think a lot of new
year's resolutions that people do make
are not are not particularly realistic
either in general or for for them
as the person that they are they should
probably pare them down a bit
um i think another problem is that
people and
this is not really a problem for me but
i can imagine this being a problem
for some people they get competitive
about their new year's resolutions
they're like
um well so and so on instagram made this
resolution
and i'd better at least match them or
do better than them and and this can
happen in friends groups or frenemy
groups this can happen
with colleagues or fellow students or
whoever right family members are
particularly prone to this sort of thing
i think um and and that's that's
not particularly helpful either
if you get in if you're making a
commitment
as a reactive way to respond
to somebody else maybe you should like
focus on your competitiveness
is the thing to work on this this year
um the other thing that i think is
really
interesting about the notion of
resolutions so when you make a
resolution
it's like making a vow right you're
making a commitment
and you're saying i'm gonna do x or not
do x like you could say i'm gonna quit
drinking this year right
i'm gonna stop smoking well what happens
after you
break down and have a drink or have a
smoke or
you know you if you're gonna do the
whole like i'm gonna exercise every day
if you don't do it
then you feel like crap because now
you've broken this big
thing that you you made right the new
year's resolution
and there's two tendencies that that
come along with this one
and they're both like reactive
tendencies they're not they're not very
well thought out one is to say oh i'm
gonna make up for this
i'm gonna fix this by doing more
tomorrow now with quitting drinking or
quitting smoking there's
not a hell of a lot you can do in terms
of fixing it that way
is there um you've broken it and and uh
you can like go back to okay well i'm at
day one of not not
doing this activity um but it's not like
you can
doubly not smoke the day after that but
if it's exercise you're studying a
language maybe you're like well i'm
gonna put in two hours instead of one
hour
well that's not really sustainable and
if you fail to do that then you feel
even more like crap right and it turns
into this big
ball the other thing that people
sometimes do is they're like oh i broke
it
there's no point to it anymore oh it's
it's all
terrible right which is another way of
overreacting to it
and you know if it was something good
that you you did commit to
you you probably do want to get yourself
back on track with it don't you
so i think the idea of
resolutions maybe in the past it had
more
value but i think for a lot of us living
the kind of lives that we live
today it might be better to think of it
in a different way and so i'm going to
address all these questions and comments
in a bit some of them might kind of
dovetail with
with what i'm gonna suggest here so
i think it first of all i think it's
perfectly
a-okay for anybody who's made a new
year's resolution
to at this point in time say i
misspoke i should have thought this out
better
um it's you know we're january 3rd maybe
maybe i'll choose by the seventh to
decide what my
real commitments are going to be i need
to give this more
thought it's okay to take it back it's
okay to say
i'm gonna redo this that would be being
prudent right that would be
an intelligent rational way of
addressing over committing oneself
so i think that's perfectly fine i think
another thing that i've seen in the
literature out there and there are some
really good blog posts that i've run
across
in the past i don't have any like ready
at hand unfortunately
but but you could probably just google
it some people suggest
replacing resolutions with something
else where
it's framed differently like having a
goal if you have a goal and you don't
meet your goal
it's not the end of the world right you
didn't like break a
vow or commitment to somebody or the
universe or
whoever you made it to you just didn't
fulfill your goal
and you can like you can you can decide
whether you want whether it was a
realistic goal or whether you want to
try to figure out how
you didn't get there and what you need
to do in order to do that
you might frame it in terms of like
wishes or desires or choices
something that's a little bit lower what
would we call it lower pressure
than a new year's resolution so it could
still be a new year's thing right but
but it doesn't have to necessarily be a
resolution or
a sacred vow that we're we're taking
um i think you know when we when we
think of it too in terms of
goals or you know intentions
we can also introduce another element
instead of it just being like about
doing something every day
or not doing something we can introduce
a different kind of tracking
or or keeping on top of these things
charting things like did i do a good job
with this or do
did i you know do kind of a bad job with
this
what do i have to do uh in order to
do better with this and it's it's very
smart
to expect smaller things of yourself at
the beginning like think about if you're
going to talk about
i'm going to like now i don't measure my
weightlifting in terms of like how much
i can bench but i know a lot of people
who do
um so like if i was like yeah i'm gonna
i'm gonna get up to benching
you know i'm not gonna say like my body
weight because that would be an
incredible amount of weight
uh i'm gonna bench 200 pounds or
something like that
well you're sure you're not gonna do
that january third you know
if if you're just going back to the gym
you better start out with not even like
two big plates on the side
uh which would be 45 45 45 right
like 135 pounds maybe you need just
maybe just just just the bar
you know at the start right and same
thing with with other things like if
you're gonna quit smoking
maybe you don't say okay i'm throwing
away all my packs maybe you go from a
pack a day
down to half a pack a day for a couple
weeks
and then a third of a pack and then a
quarter of a pack and you know you you
taper off because that's been being more
realistic and you could chart that right
there's all sorts of apps i i suppose
that you could do that with
um another thing is i think if we frame
it in terms of goals
we're probably going to be a little bit
more realistic
and less like sweeping i'm gonna change
my whole life i mean
it might be good to think about why we
are
so and this is a if the shoe fits
you know wear it sort of thing i'm sure
that a lot of you aren't this way
but i know i've been this way in the
past where we're like so like i'm gonna
change my life
totally you know why do we have to be so
hyperbolic about these things
why why can't we just be more measured
and
and prudent about it is it that it's not
exciting enough for us
well that's something to take a look at
i think right
and then lastly we can think about
perseverance and it is a good thing to
develop perseverance a lot of that is a
matter of
you know so anselm has a great uh
analysis of
what that is he calls it perseverance
persevere
is to will the same thing continuously
or committedly per vale in
in latin um to choose
to to make a a choice about
what we're going to do and a lot of that
is like picking ourselves up after we
fall down
so perseverance is not just the person
who
wills the right thing over and over and
over again and then you know like in
every temptation
rises above the temptation it's also the
person who
falls but says oh
crap let's let's start over it's sort of
like those
those uh things where it says like you
know 45 days in the plant without an
accident and then there's an accident
and now it's zero days well
you know tomorrow it'll be one more day
and then
two days you just have to but it won't
be that if you don't like choose to get
back
on the proverbial horse right after
you've fallen off
so i'm going to do one more thing before
i start
addressing these uh many comments
i'm going to tell you about the the 10
things that
as i was thinking about this
particularly on my walks over the last
couple days
things that i decided i wanted to do for
myself this year
and they're not really resolutions as
such some of them aren't even really
goals
but they're they're things that i
thought you know what's actually going
to make my life
better and these are just basically for
me
my wife and i also have um
a whole set of things as well as a
couple
but these are the ones for me so i
decided that
in the morning i really need to do some
daily reading
and the two things that i'm reading
regularly little bits and pieces of in
the morning
are i'm reading um a re-reading rather
actually all this is rereading seneca's
uh i'm a happy life and i'm doing that
in part because i'm doing a
collaborative thing with tim labon about
stoic zest and so that that's a great
one for that but you know i'm so i'm
i'm reading you know like uh uh
10 pages or so uh in the morning and
then i've been
going back to one of my my favorite
works um
anselm's prayers and i've been reading
the prayer to john the baptist
if you don't know saint anselm's saint
anselm revolutionary is praying
believe it or not and his prayers are
these incredibly
interesting compositions that were
designed to be used in multiple ways by
multiple people
this also ties in with a a collaborative
thing that i'm doing with a friend of
mine from oslo
harold um i'm going to be
writing an email to him later today
about why he needs to take a look at
this because he's gotten interested in
anselm in certain ways in which anselm's
ethics and stoic ethics come together
and so that that shows in his prayers
but you could read whatever you
wanted i mean i i'm going to move on
from those eventually but
doing it in the morning before you know
when when the light is good
and when i'm just having my coffee and
i've got the cat
fed you know and chilling out a bit uh
before i jump in the day's work
that's something i know is good for me
um
another thing i'm to be doing more of is
is
just saying no to things saying no to
invitations and commitments to do this
extra thing over here
uh so that i can save my time for for
other things and
you know i've been i've been doing that
um in a certain way with like
when i when i deal with with people who
are cantankerous
or uh a kind of a pain in my my rear
on comments or twitter or stuff like
that i just i just you know
block them or or remove their comments
and then
that's the end of the conversation
because social media is sort of like
putting yourself to this giant room
where any person in the world can come
up to you and
and uh start ranting at you and you
don't have to put up with that
so i i'm i'm doing that uh another thing
i mean a lot of you've probably seen my
my pictures if you if you follow
my social media from my walks i'm gonna
try to take walks pretty
much almost every day not necessarily
every day because my knees
sometimes hurt a bit uh you know i'm 50
years old i've
put them through a lot of stuff and
sometimes walking
long distances can be a little bit hard
on them especially in the cold of winter
but
i i know it really helps my mood
to go take walks around our beautiful
city that we have here
um and to be out in nature
and you know listen sometimes to a
podcast or to some
some metal stuff um so that that's
something i'm going to be doing a good
bit more of
um starting out the morning with some
some
metal you know i don't listen to enough
music i know what i
like i know what i'm into um
[Music]
i really do enjoy uh just sometimes just
listening and
uh seeing what's going on in these these
compositions some of which are
50 years old you know um
yeah 50 years old going back to 1970
71 would be this year right um
and just thinking about what's what's
what's happening with the song
and stuff like that and
um what else uh
i wrote a whole list here so enjoying
artwork
um obviously we can't really go to art
museums at this point in time or art
galleries
but there's so much online and i mean
through my little screen right here i
could go to
virtually so many museums
and i want to start incorporating more
especially from my milwaukee institute
of art and design classes more
artwork into the classes which means i
need to spend some time doing sort of
stuff that i used to like to do
going to galleries and just like looking
at stuff and
and taking it in you know so i'm going
to be doing more of that
um i want to do more writing and
research work
you know i've got a medium that i hardly
ever write in i've got a couple blogs
that i started as
little rewards for myself like heavy
metal philosopher
and i'd never get around to writing in
it this this year i should get back to
that and because that gives me joy and
you know that's uh it's a lot of fun for
me and
some people seem to enjoy reading it
that ties in with another thing which is
playing my my instruments a bit more i'm
looking over there because they're in
the other room my
my banjo and my bass guitar
i need to fix the action on the bass
because my my daughter
adjusted it way down and it's got a bit
of fret buzz
because of that i need the action way up
so i can you know
eliminate that because it drives me nuts
but i you know i i'd really like to
start playing more regularly start
putting in the practice so that
my uh my fingers can do the sorts of
things that i want them to do
um i want to start lifting weights again
um obviously i can't go to the gym you
know we're still in lockdown here
and the people who do go to the gym are
usually the least safe people
so so i'm not going to the wisconsin
athletic club but i do have dumbbells
that i
bought back in college and i could just
start using
those i really enjoy uh
working with those so
start doing some circuit training um
i'm going to start doing some weekly
reach outs to friends
family members you know scheduling a bit
of time to
to reconnect with people colleagues too
especially i'm going to point that that
direction that that's
that direction is where marquette
university is there we go
uh to the west of us and some of my
colleagues i think may have been losing
their jobs this
current semester so i need to reach out
to them and see how they're doing and uh
maybe commiserate with them a bit um but
it's it's a good thing you know being
connected with other people
is is a very important way of keeping
your your spirits up especially in our
covid times right and what else do i
have here there was one other thing that
i can't do right now
and some of you will respond those of
you in the midwest say
well yeah you can fishing um i used to
really enjoy
fishing when i was a kid and you know as
a teen and in my 20s and
even in my 30s i used to take my
daughter fishing with me
um and she you know kind of putter
around but
uh that that was that was fun i haven't
done it for years and years and years
live in a great place for doing fishing
[Music]
i'd like to start doing it again and
somebody will say well you could be
doing it right now do ice fishing
well that's interesting because it
hasn't been cold enough for us to have
really safe ice here yet
due to global warming here in wisconsin
but
i don't really like ice fishing because
for me that's the sort of thing you got
to do with with
if you've got like family members or
buddies and you're going to sit out
there on the ice and like drink beers
and
[ __ ] because it takes a long time
for anything to happen i switch
and it's kind of it's kind of hard on
the body you know my feet get cold
pretty quickly
so i i don't think ice fishing is is for
me but eventually i wanted to start
doing
you know some some fishing and i i when
i fish
i'm not really that concerned about how
much i'm catching i'm not one of those
sport fishermen
i just like to go out and you know be in
nature and cast it and maybe catch
something that i can eat or
or maybe not maybe i'll just do catch
and release
so that's that's the sort of stuff that
i'm gonna do
i'd be interested to hear what some of
you want to do for your year
coming up um so i'm gonna read through
these
comments now um
let's see here rt whitby says
one of my favorite quotes is we learned
from history that we do not learn from
history
yeah that's the case with a lot of
people um
uh tail quinn says i gave up resolutions
and i'm happy with my years
so yeah uh dammit albert says leave me
alone it's still january
yeah you know maybe maybe it's it's kind
of a bad idea for us to have this
tradition of like making all of our
resolutions at the beginning of the year
maybe what we actually need is like you
know
couple weeks and then we think you know
real soberly and maybe consult a couple
people but
what should we do this this this coming
year and then we we
turn in our goals by end of february or
something like that you know
uh that would be kind of smart dc frank
traditions tend to endure
even when they've proven to be obsolete
yeah that's that's quite true and
it's usually because of i think there's
two main reasons one is we have
emotional attachments to traditions like
if you
ask me why you know
i want to do certain things at christmas
time
or you know our attachment to certain
dishes so
one of one of the biggest things i
missed this christmas was
some of the food that we we typically
have
you know like in my family we have
tootsie which is a
french canadian meat pie and we have a
family recipe for it
and then it's also a tradition in my
family that
one of the men makes oyster soup used to
be my grandpa
and then you know we have other things
like the booster noel this big christmas
cake
and not having that um it's not gonna
you know it's not
really weighing on me or anything but um
you have emotional attachments to these
these sorts of things and you might have
like
you know for all sorts of holidays right
thanksgiving
fourth of july valentine's day right
all those are are things that people
form that and then there's
the like what will people say
if we don't xyz where it's less about
you enjoying it and it's more about
we have to do this because it's expected
you know and i think it caught there's a
lot of stuff like that that causes a lot
of people a lot of
a lot of grief so if we don't do new
year's resolutions we're
we're like letting other people down and
yeah
it's kind of irrational right uh rt
says the journey of a thousand miles
begins with a single step
yeah that's that's a good thing to keep
in mind and
the good news about that is you can
restart that step right
so oh this is a really interesting
suggestion from
x blue bells hubby and i do an end of
year mind map they're fun to look over
so is that like um
you know like a mind map of like things
that you find
valuable or things you want to remove
from your life that
that you know that would actually be a
lot of fun to do
i imagine um that might be something
that my my wife and i might might pick
up on
ourselves looking over at her right now
because she likes mind maps a bit more
than i do
giving a thumbs up so good suggestion
there
uh dc frank i think the main reason why
new year's resolutions are pointless is
because there's no stakes
if somebody doesn't honor their
resolution there's no consequence to
them
yeah well so we could we could make new
year's resolutions even more anxiety
provoking
by introducing stakes like you have to
put up some money
or um somebody gets to smack you or
something like that
or you get you get you know uh if you
don't make your new year's resolution
people pile on you in social media
um it's interesting so i'm gonna give a
little bit of a digression here
many of you may know that i am
involved in um
uh you know a lot of online groups
which were originally face-to-face
groups like the you know milwaukee stoic
fellowship
now we don't do this but another one of
the stoic fellowship groups in new york
does this
they have a practice group where when
you join
you pay in like a hundred bucks or i
think 120 bucks i think they it's it's
120 bucks for the year
and for each meeting that you make
and where you're doing the stuff that
you're doing the host
pays you back some of your money and if
you don't do it then it goes into the
communal kitty right um
and it gets people you know it it's it's
not like you should do it to earn the
money but it provides
an accountability incentive uh andy was
just
my wife is just pointing out to me that
healthy wage which both of us are doing
also does something kind of similar you
pay in a certain amount per month
and you you wager on um
how much weight you're going to lose and
if you make it then you get
a payout and if you don't it goes back
into the to the kiddies so
that's a good example as well
uh x blue bells also says i i notice
it's not always good to
up your goals i noticed when i said i
wanted to get faster at my french
learning it actually made it less fun
yeah it put additional pressure and made
it less fun
yeah when when you um
when it starts like impinging upon
other things like if i say i'm going to
work out you know two hours each day
okay that's two hours of time i don't
have to do other stuff
and that could you know that could be
great if i really like working out but
it could also suck if it's
me making me not do other things that i
want to do and
there's something about once you've made
a commitment to do something that you
enjoy
doing sometimes it is less fun right
because you're doing it now because you
you made a commitment so i think that's
that's
totally on um
rt says uh i've seen people who think
that
if they don't achieve 100 of their goal
then they're a failure but achieving 50
of their goal is still an achievement
yeah this is this is a big big problem
um and i fall into this myself sometimes
it's all or nothing
thinking this failure to recognize that
something that is good is good
even if it's not ideal even if it's not
the best
all of you i'm sure heard that that
proverb don't let the best be
the good or the best is the enemy of the
good um
that is a real issue
for us and i think it might be i think
in the internet
um uh pervaded
uh you know sort of always-on
setting that we're in i think there's
more of a tendency towards that kind of
perfectionism because it's easier to
like look at
all the other things that we're not
doing and to see
like peak performers and to measure
ourselves
against that and so if we're not doing
like the best thing then then we're
we we suck we're not you know we're not
any good
um and so you know it is really
important
to recognize that so let's take weight
loss right if you if you have some
unrealistic thing like i'm gonna lose 70
pounds i'm gonna
you know people are like i'm gonna get
back to my high school weight right
um which could be realistic if you're
like in college
but even in college you should probably
weigh a little bit more than your high
school weight because your body's still
still growing um but if you're like 40
years old and you're like i'm gonna get
back to my high school weight that's
that's nutty
uh unless your high school weight was
you know a
a decent healthy thing for somebody
who's actually 40 years old
but if you if you um if you lose 10
pounds you lost 10 pounds that's less
pressure on your knees
your feet and you know your
cardiovascular system
it's it's it's something if you say that
i'm going to reach out
and and contact a person per day that i
haven't talked to
and you only manage to do it once a week
that's still
you know by the end of the year 50
people that you've you've reached out to
so i think that's that's a really good
point
cody says something kind of like this i
found small lifestyle changes to be
helpful most time the changes i make
don't happen january
first yeah i mean i'm i'm not
like a new year's partier anymore you
know
um although i i used to be back in the
past
um and and i think like for a lot of
people you're not going to make changes
on new year's day if you're hungover
or you know recovering from all all the
stuff that you've been doing over the
holiday season
um and then the nice thing about new
year's day is it's usually pretty quiet
here
um like i went did take a walk new
year's day
which is kind of nice but yeah these um
these big changes are probably not going
to happen on the first
all right donald says i've seen many new
year's resolutions on twitter to be so
broad as to be almost meaningless yeah
so these are some great examples i'm
going to listen more and talk less
or even moral goals that are not easily
measurable
regret less be more kind yeah that's a
great point
so goals should be more specific
otherwise you can't track i mean how do
you track listen
more talk less i guess you could like
you could somehow have an ai that would
like listen to
how many minutes you talk and then
how does it check how you listen i don't
know
you could do something like that i
suppose with
like if listening and talking was about
um
social media you could be like well how
many how many things that i
like or actually like read versus how
many did i
comment on or how many posts that i make
um that would be more actionable but now
it's no longer just listen less taught
listen more talk less and now it's
been reduced to something else right
um so that yeah that's a that's a great
point there's a lot of really
vague resolutions i'm gonna be a kinder
person well what the hell does that mean
you know i mean how do you measure that
how do you how do you take stock of that
and how do you keep yourself from lying
to yourself
about exchanges that you had where you
were unkind
uh but you somehow managed to spin it so
that you're you're kind
and i i guess we could ask why do people
make those sorts of posts in social
media is it because they want attention
is it because it makes them feel good
about themselves i think i think a good
bit of posting on social media is kind
of reflexive perhaps even narcissistic
where people are like showing themselves
to the world but it's really about them
showing themselves to themselves
but that's a whole different topic um
all right uh damn it albert says are you
a metal head yeah
i'm i've been a metal head for a very
long time i got into it as a kid and
been doing it for a while john reeves
says i can tell you've lost some weight
whatever you're doing it's working
yeah i've lost some weight from a while
ago
um part of it is just like
getting more more good sleep um you know
taking those walks is is helpful because
that burns calories and
it's good for my my body in general um
we eat pretty healthy
you know um we we don't order in a lot
that's that's probably a big help right
there
you know we both my wife and i are good
cooks
and um you know we understand
food pretty intimately you know like how
what goes with what and
different methods and things like that
so you know we
we we eat pretty pretty well um
[Music]
so yeah that and it's it's important i i
have to
keep losing some weight especially for
my knees you know
as i'm getting older i'm realizing
these uh these joints aren't going to
last forever
you know and i don't want to be like my
uncle john who
boy i think
around my age maybe a little bit older
he had both knees replaced um
and now they're they're getting close to
the end of their
they don't have a warranty on them or
anything like that but you know
these artificial joints are not made to
last forever so he's gonna have to have
some sort of
uh intervention before too long so
all right rt says i've gotten lost in
the virtual british museum well that's
interesting yeah i'll have to check that
out
i'm i'm actually planning on beginning
with local uh uh museums in their site
so we have the
milwaukee art museum which is is
wonderful and then there's the
um i forget exactly what it's called the
the on-campus gallery from marquette
university
i'm sure there's something at uw
milwaukee
um i should check to see i mean i could
actually like
probably spend a lot of time just going
through my students works uh
at milwaukee institute of art design um
there's so much online from
from them and then um
you know there's the frank kohler up in
sheboygan that i like i'm gonna see what
they have online
and um there's probably a whole bunch of
other ones and then i'm gonna start
branching out like in a look at the
chicago
art institute that'll probably keep me
busy for a number of days
but yeah all right cody says i picked up
a couple art books and planned to focus
on one piece
at a time that's a great idea as a
matter of fact we have a ton
of art books around here
some of them may be in boxes but we've
got we've got a ton of them we also have
a ton of
like culinary books you know
um and looking at some of those
as compositions might be might be a good
idea
as well uh
skip says there are so many excellent
slide shows of hundreds of artists
throughout the years
uh ins vigo has a great account
i'll have to check that out
um i just skipped a little bit here we
go joseph says i don't like the polarity
of resolutions
maybe the mark of a moral person is the
ability to navigate the nuance between
the success and failure of such things
isn't life lived within the nuance part
of life is i mean part of life is also
making
the end points as well um
i i think you can do resolutions in ways
that are more prudent
not calling them resolutions is probably
a big part of that
um but yeah dealing with success and
dealing with failure
is a really important part of moral life
that we don't often emphasize enough
like in ethics classes i i often you
know when i taught ethics very
regularly i used to tell my my students
ethics is in large part about figuring
out how to fix
things after you've screwed them up and
i think that's that's still quite true
i should probably do a video about that
sometime
um damn it albert says definitely want
to work on french and latin
that's that's always good to do skip
says thinking about going to get a
fourth degree at bfa
bachelor's of fine arts that's that's
pretty cool as well
um 20 years ago what do you think is the
best to do this year to avoid thinking
about the pandemic
well i don't think you should avoid
thinking about the pandemic altogether
you know it's a question of thinking
about the particularly crappy aspects of
the pandemic i think i think a lot of
dodges that people have had
you know and when i say that i mean like
coping mechanisms
are actually quite good like the you
know posting pictures of your cat
and talking about them being your
co-worker when they're doing silly
things
that comes out of the pandemic but but
it's not it's to take our mind off the
pandemic
it's kind of fun to do um i mean
having having things that occupy your
time
because they're not you're not just
trying to like kill time but because
they're intrinsically
interesting like like again think about
the looking at
art right um and learning more about the
artist
and kind of like trying to lose yourself
in the work
that's very different than just like
opening up an art book and flipping
through it and trying to kill an
hour here and there there's and we're
really fortunate because with the
internet we have so much content whether
visual you know like images or
podcasts or videos
with all the stuff available on youtube
or streaming
providers you know you could
there's so much that you could you could
do and you could study
um then there's you know
books that you can read and there's
exercises to do
um there's there's a lot of great stuff
out there
so yeah um
zeno says solitude is sometimes best
society yeah it depends on
on you know what your solitude is like
some people like aristotle pointed this
out
some people just can't be by themselves
you know
julian suggests having new year's
resolutions but keeping them
secret you can do that
it's still going to be subject to some
of the same
problems even if you're not telling
other people about them
you know zoltar says working
on my first draft plan still going to
turn in the finished resolutions for
chinese new year
that's a good idea yeah yeah i like that
um
i can bounce it out to alternate new
years
andrew says i think yearly resolutions
aren't a good idea
what i think is cognizant
self-reflection weekly monthly maybe
there's too long a time before
reflecting on it if we manage to achieve
the new year's resolutions
that's that's right i i think that
if we're only really measuring things at
a year
uh i mean a year might be a convenient
measure for some things like i don't
know financial plans or something like
that
um but yeah it's probably too long of a
period for
for a lot of stuff um
maybe we should have resolutions that we
like try on for a month
you know or a week and we're like
does this help me out let me let me make
a commitment to this
and then we'll see where it goes from
there you know
i think that could be a good idea
all right uh skip says i find them
vacuous i tend to make an effort to
change grow or make appeals to myself
throughout the year
okay so that's good too uh akash
should i who calls himself a stoic take
new year's resolutions
sounds counterintuitive there's nothing
anti-stoic about
uh doing new year's resolutions there's
nothing particularly stoic about it
either
again you might want to check out that
that workshop that i linked to that i
did a couple years back on
using uh stoic principles to reassess
new year's resolutions so
um zoltar says maybe
make a resolution sorry to make it more
enjoyable or convenient
so so a sort of meta resolution right
um like a resolution to
to uh
i mean this could be actually a good
idea
you make a you make a commitment so
you're doing the thing
and you build into it this idea that
down the line
you're going to assess am i this goes
back to that that that previous thing
am i really enjoying what i'm doing or
am i finding this to be tedious you know
like i committed myself to something
and past me locked me into something
that present me doesn't doesn't get
anything out of
it's it's sterile that could actually be
a great way to
to reassess uh these commitments
um here's a question from michael are
there any academic fields other than
philosophy which you're passionate about
learning
or teaching so my my teaching
uh in the past has ranged over quite a
few things
i've taught classes in religious studies
critical thinking which is within
philosophy but kind of
an outlier and also ties in with
arguments and rhetoric
i've taught humanities classes
i've taught some literature classes so
yeah i mean for me philosophy is is not
just what gets labeled as philosophy on
the bookshelf or
in academic departments it covers quite
a
range including political science um
[Music]
some things that would fall under
psychology sociology
there's a lot of things that i'm not
really competent to teach about
but i'll sometimes like dabble in them
for my students but i don't pretend to
any great expertise
um you know i mean i
i also have that classic metal class
that i do with scott geruli
once a month as sort of a side project
to indulge myself where i'm doing some
musicology stuff
you know oftentimes we do bring in
philosophy with that but yeah
all right um dc frank says
from experience as well as observing
people's behavior the thing that really
gets people to change their ways
is when one is confronted with their
mortality it's a very eye-opening
experience
that's that's one big thing that can
change it another thing that can really
change people's behavior
is realizing um the harm that they're
doing to other people
you know so it's not just one's own
vulnerability it could be like
oh wow you know now that i'm a parent
i can't do this anymore because there's
this young person
depending on me like you know say
smoking right
now that i'm a parent i need to stay
alive
longer so that i'm not imposing you know
all this this uh
loss and abandonment on on my kids
or that i'm i'm actually going to be in
decent enough to health to
to do things with them or you know and
there's other things as well that we
could have
where it provokes a
a rethinking moment an openness to to
change
you know um
yeah all right uh
joseph says i'm quite interested in a
stoic's take on adopting new year's
resolutions could they fit inside the
school of thought new year's resolutions
are
definitely cyclic stoics um you know
uh if you read stoic literature there
there's all sorts of stuff about making
you know commitments
and about assessing whether you're doing
well or not with them you know
um oh it just skipped again
here we go louis perez says what roman
greek god would you identify with
if you live in those times or which is
your favorite in general
um i don't know
it's a good question not what i've
thought about before
probably athena you know goddess of
wisdom um
lover of uh odysseus um
a ranger of all sorts of things the one
who set up aphrodite
for a hit in the iliad uh when she uh
allowed was it diameters to see her and
then
go after her with a spear yeah all right
dc frank long here scruff scruffy beer
simple sports team t-shirt despite being
an academic with a doctorate
yeah he's amused metalhead r.a.p lemmy
well you know the packers are playing
today that's that you know and
this is actually a good year um so i
usually wear my
my packer shirt uh when they're going to
play
because you know as we know from charlie
day of always sunny
uh every single thing that every single
fan does affects the game
right um so yeah
uh cody says i found rollerblading to be
very easy on my joints
i i tried rollerblading years and years
and years ago but i didn't really get
into it
um i don't think that i probably would i
i used to skateboard
and i could see myself if i lost a bit
of weight
maybe getting a skateboard again that
could be kind of fun
uh first name last name don't know if
you've talked about this before but what
do you think about the wish happy new
year might mean other than a pleasantry
what might be a better alternative wish
one might say besides happy
i mean i don't think that we don't need
to i don't think we need to replace
happy new year i'm
cool with wishing people a happy new
year
so that's not really one i'd worry about
uh j two nick is a black man how should
i feel about the fact that trump was
elected in the first place
um there's a lot of different ways you
could feel about it right
um but i don't know that that's that
relevant
here 20 years ago i remember my neighbor
promising never to drink as new year
in 2021 never happened yeah people make
all sorts of
people actually make all sorts of
resolutions about drinking just when
they're hung over right they're like i'm
never going to drink again and then you
know the next day they're
they're drunk
all right uh bled back to life what are
your thoughts on the use of psychedelics
as tools of philosophical inquiry and
personal transformation i would say they
can be useful at a very beginning
stage um i don't buy into like the
opening the doors of perceptions
stuff i think that they're kind of a
attempted to um
to shortcut stuff and um
there are no no real shortcuts in in
philosophy so
um i'm not not a big big fan of it i
don't have a problem with people using
them recreationally but
i don't think that the musings of of
people
who are high or you know tripping are
particularly
interesting so
all right uh ethy says what do i think
about philosophy students who scold
people
for extensively studying plato they
think if you haven't read fukuonita
then you're pretty much stupid um i
would say those are nut jobs
um or they're part of some you know like
they're part of like a club and it's
it's interesting
um so there's there's quite a few
programs
where people study whatever is
considered cutting edge
right and it doesn't have to necessarily
be reading continental philosophy it
could also be reading contemporary
analytic philosophy and they don't learn
about the
long rich history of philosophy so they
don't actually read any plato or
descartes
or anselm you know other than little
snippets
to you know reject plato's
phallocentrism or some stuff like that
right
and then they actually spend some time
reading it and they're like holy [ __ ] i
was robbed
you know i i my my uh professors
told me that this is what plato was
saying and i didn't read it myself and
now that i'm reading it i'm like wow
there's so much stuff here you know
um plus you don't really know what
you're reacting against if you don't if
you
if you haven't read descartes and really
like studied some descartes
saying stuff about cartesianism is just
sort of blathering right
um same thing with like criticizing
aristotle or plato or any of these sorts
of things
so i i don't know i would just ignore
them they
they uh they don't have anything to
contribute you know right
um let's see here
wavy says uh considering you speak
multiple languages
just skipped a little bit uh
here we go do you have any advice for
those planning to learn a new language
as their resolution for 2021 um yeah i
mean
if you want to learn a language plan to
put in
a lot of time at least an hour a day
consistently
it's an iterative building process and
you want to do it on multiple fronts
um so you know you can do something like
get yourself an
app or a program like rosetta stone or
duolingo or something like that but
sooner or later you also want to start
like
reading things in the language you also
want to like
determine are you learning the language
so that you can like
read classic texts are you learning it
so you can talk to people on the street
because those aren't the same thing
you know like nobody nobody speaks
classic greek right but we read
classic greek and there's you know like
plato's
greek and then there's you know
pre-socratic stuff which is in a
different dialect and then there's like
the coin a
stuff there's even byzantine greek which
i guess is different i don't really know
because i don't
i haven't read any of those authors um
but that's that's like a whole different
thing than like learning german so that
you can like get on the train and talk
to people and like sit around the stomp
dish and have
beers with people uh but you wanna you
wanna put in time you wanna you wanna
make sure that you're doing it every day
and it's one of those things too where
you're gonna
you're gonna feel at a lot of points
like you're not making progress
but you are making progress building a
language is sort of like building
a unconscious substructure that
eventually you get to the point it's
sort of like learning an instrument
right
you do all these scales and and you're
like oh this is
such boring [ __ ] why do i have to do
this but then
suddenly you realize at some point in
time wow i i
i know what key i'm in i can transpose
this
and holy crap now i've got an ability so
learning languages
is a lot like that i'd say
samira says um i quit smoking because my
daughter asked me to quit
that that's that's great you know i
remember when i was a kid
we had this uh kitchen and then we had
what was called a dinette which is like
a little
area off the kitchen where you have like
a small dining room table
and that's where we ate dinner when i
was a kid and
we would be sitting there my sister and
i and my mom and dad and grandpa would
all be smoking at the table this is the
1970s right
before all these studies on second hand
smoke came out
and it was just like you know it was
like being in an old bar
you know there was all this haze in the
air and we'd be like oh please don't
smoke at the table
they'd be like it's okay you know um so
it's cool that you quit because your
daughter asked you to
um right michael says
uh thanks for the response to your
question
college years of philosophy led to
getting a degree in mandarin and
international studies with a focus in
east asian studies that's very cool
um it says i start my masters in public
policy next fall i'm interested in
seeing how my philosophical political
science brain will influence my approach
to policy theories and applications
hopefully it'll have some some stuff
that's relevant i will say this
one of the things that i've realized
in in doing consulting with
organizations
and in doing a lot of work with
businesses is that what we do in
philosophy
is not something magical but it is
something that a lot of people don't do
which is
asking the right questions and even more
than that
making distinctions at the right point
and it's
it's not anything that anybody couldn't
do they're just not trained to do it
and we do it almost unconsciously so we
hear people like having an argument and
we're like
oh you guys are arguing because you're
using this term in this way and he's
using this term in this way
and then they're like wow that's amazing
you know
i think you're going to see a lot of
stuff like that where where things that
you kind of take for granted
other people just um you know
they don't do it that often so
all right um we're gonna we're almost
out of time and i've got to do some
stuff pretty soon i got some work to do
today before the game
so i'm gonna grab a couple easy to
answer things
um let's see here
uh
[Music]
a lot of back and forth discussions here
so rt whitby says
the owl is a symbol of wisdom because
the owl was the symbol of athena the
goddess of wisdom
yep that's that's that's quite true it's
here's a good one to go out on monas
says which books would be good to read
before going to university to study
philosophy whatever philosophy books you
want
because you're going to reread them and
you know
you're going to get introduced to all
sorts of cool stuff
so it's not like you have to do prep
before you get to university to study
philosophy
and if you run into prick professors who
are like oh you should have read this or
that
uh they don't know what they're talking
about and they're they don't speak for
the rest of the profession
so you can you know read whatever you
read whatever you want to
um let's see if we got uh
um
here's a really good absurdist one from
bob foster as a trans toaster with
barely repressed feelings from my
hamster
how should i feel about fiser shares
plummeting and the answer of course is
42 right
if we're going to do jokey stuff and
here's an interesting one so lr writes
ac graylings the history of philosophy
is very good
it's not i i i looked through it
there's a lot of major emissions in it
um
and and i i was getting ready to work on
a collaborative piece on woolstonecraft
where we're
basically saying you know she's been
ignored within the history of moral
philosophy and the history of modern
philosophy
wrongly so um grayling
is just a repeater of that sort of thing
so
good on the things that that are covered
not so good on the emissions
which are startling hardly any women
philosophers
uh who deserve to be in the history of
philosophy in that contemporary
history of philosophy book here's
another one what do you think of
russell's history of western philosophy
don't bother with it read cobblestone
instead russell has
access to grind he's a good writer but
he's
not a he's not a good philosopher when
it comes to the history of philosophy
um so all right so it's already a
minute over what we're going to do i do
have to get to some some work
uh thanks for everybody for for tuning
in uh
this is this is enjoyable helped me to
get some of my own ideas clear
and uh you know hopefully your
resolutions if you've made them you feel
empowered to break them
rework them structure them however you
like so that it leads to
a more enjoyable way of committing
yourself
uh in this this uh hopefully better
2021 than 2020 was so
i'll see all of you later and of course
go pack go